اهلا بكم سيبقى اسم المغرب مسطرا باحرف من
ذهب في سجلات اغلى البطولات كاس العالم
قبل لحظات انطلقت مباراه المنتخب المغربي
ونظيره الفرنسي في نصف نهائي مونديال قطر
يتقابل فيها الصديقان اشرف حكيمي
والفرنسيه كيليان مبابي مقابله الخصمان
منتخب اسود الاطلس اخترق السقف الوهمي
الذي لم تتمكن المنتخبات العربيه ولا
الافريقيه من اختراقه دور الثمانيه ثلاث
محاولات افريقيه سابقه بائت بالفشل
الكاميرون عام 1990 والسنغال عام 2002
وغانا عام 2010 كان خط النهايه دور ربع
النهائي
المنتخب المغربي تجاوز هذا الخط للمغرب
اولا وللمنتخبات الافريقيه
وللعربي ثانيه ليست هذه الاطراف وحدها من
يدعمها المنتخب المغربي اذ نشهد او تشهد
دول عده دول عالميه مؤازره كبيره من مختلف
القارات للمغرب الحصان الاسود في هذه
البطوله انطلقت المباراه منذ لحظات كما
ذكرنا وسنعرف نتيجه هل الليله لكن ايا
كانت النتيجه يبقى الانجاز المغربي كبيرا
وتخطى حدود المملكه المغربيه ودول العربيه
والقاره الافريقيه ليكتب اسم المغرب كاحد
افضل اربعه منتخبات في العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المنتخب المغربي
تاريخ كره القدم العربيه والافريقيه
ومحاوله الوصول الى نهائي بطوله كاس
العالم مدرب المنتخب وليد الرجراجي يتساءل
لما لا نصل الى نهائي كاس العالم واكد ان
فريقه سيبدي رغبه كبيره كما سيحاول تحقيقه
مفاجاه اكد الرجراجي ان منتخبه جاء الى
هذه البطوله لتغيير العقليات داخل القاره
الافريقيه والهام الاجيال القادمه من
اللاعبين والمنتخبات بان التفاني والاصرار
يجعل ما يتصوره البعض مستحيلا على الورق
امرا واقعيه على الميدان الاخضر لائحه
الانتصارات المغربيه في هذه البطوله ضمت
اثناء بلجيكا وكندا في دور المجموعات
واسبانيا في الدور الثاني واخيرا البرتغال
في ربع النهائي المباراه التاريخيه تدور
الان سودا الاطلس امام الديوك الفرنسيه
المغرب يتميز بخطوط متجانسه في حراسه
المرمى والدفاع وخط الوسط والهجوم حتى
الان تلقى المنتخب
المغربي هدفا واحدا بنران صديقه هدفان اذا
منذ لحظات اسود الاطلس وعلى لساني مدربهم
قال ان الوصول لنصف النهائي ليس الهدف
الاكبر وانا المنتخب يريد الذهاب الى ابعد
من ذلك اضاف الرجراجي ان المغرب ربما لا
يكون مرشحا للفوز لكن لاعبيه على ثقه
بقدوراتها
سنخرج من كل مباراه
لذلك كما قلت في بدايه المسابقه نحن
بالفوز بكاس العالم وكل ما تقدمنا اكثر
اقتربنا من حلولنا لذلك غدا سنكافح للمضي
قدما نحن واثقون حتى لو صارت كل التوقعات
ضمن ربما نكون مجانين ولكن من الجيد ان
تكون مجنونا